thank you
thank you merci Viola merci thank you
well
I would ask you my dear friend to bear
with me
because
it's a great great moment of emotion
and also I hit my accent when I speak
English
if I scramble on a word just upload you
don't give me more cash
to continue
and um
to have a my speech on the scouts
so I'll try to do my best okay and you
encourage me promise
okay
thank you dear member of the of the
academy Board of Governors
and thank you to everyone who came here
tonight
it's a special thing
to two brilliant female students who
came all the ways from Martinique my
native country
hearing and Salome
a few years ago
in Martinez called School
foreign
School
and I wanted absolutely wanted to have
one of the students from that school and
from another school
high school should share in Martini to
be here tonight with us because I if I
make finishes for this generation and
the one coming and it was important that
Jacob all the way with the support of
everybody's Martini to be here in that
room with you with us so they could see
it
and then go back home and explain to the
other kids what it is how it was and the
peoples they met and how important that
experience was for them
thank you
when I look at you all friends
peers colleagues mentors
memory makers
I imagine of an African proverb if you
want to go fast go alone
if you want to go far go together
ladies and gentlemen
you know in your heart
no one reaches this stage alone
and I will not be here without the
wisdom and Love of All Those Who join me
in my journey
my heart is bursting right now thinking
of my grandmother Kami of my dad Leon of
my mother Mirai
and my godmother and God feathers
is there France what we feel
thank you to all the mentors who
encouraged me like Robert Redford who
invited me to attend the students
Institute filmmakers lab in 1985 which
it were there I Workshop a dry white
season
I thank the cast
and Crews of all my film especially
those of sugarcane Ali the Bride of
bourbon Island and a dry white season
and a very important thing to the
audience is all around the world without
them my field will not be considered as
classic today
I love you all
and I would be
I would be remiss
if I did not think the source of all my
good fortunes
the almighty God
now
many have asked me why for a time I
stepped back from the career I love
the answer is I step back so I could
truly stand up and stand tall
if I didn't make any movies for a few
years
is becomes I decided to keep silence
and I kept my silence
because I was exhausted
I was so tired of being told that
I was a boner
I was so tired of hearing praises
for being the first of too many first
but denied the chance to make the movies
I compelled to make
over the years dear friends like avadi
Verne Julie Dash Nima Barnett
Gina Prince by hood and others were
calling me the queen
sharing my work
thanking me for shattering barriers and
I have been humbled very humbled by such
praise
and why do they speak of me like that
because they may have recognized and
identified with my films and the themes
embodied in them
because I am a film maker
foreign
because they may have known of the
danger I faced going undercover in South
Africa smuggling audio evidence of
apartheid victims necessary to tell the
truth about their struggle
type in my panties
I am Fearless
and I want to inspire the new generation
like my godson
Peacemaker Manuel
and Andrew
but at the end of the day
what is the point of those sincere words
because I was not being the camera doing
what I truly got me put me on this Earth
to do
in my camera
my miraculous weapon as I call it
to bring our Collective Humanity into
focus on the screen
with my camera
I I don't shoot I hear
and why I kept my silence
it was because I had lost my willingness
to hear those words
black is not bankable
female is not bankable black and female
is not bankable
come on guys Luther look at my sister
standing by me nice guy
black is bankable
female is bankable
black and female are is blinkable
yes
black and female is bankable
right Chadwick
he knows
tonight
I have been given credence
to what I have always voiced
The Impossible Is Possible
and you sparked in me so joy to shout
again
camera
sound
then action
this is my shout tonight
a shout of inclusion
of pride of happiness
I congratulate the academy for helping
to lead the charge to change our
industry
and for opening the doors to that were
close to the ideas and vision that I
championed for so long
it encourages me to raise my voice again
to offer you movies of all genres that I
always wanted to make
in my own way
without having my voice census or silent
and very importantly my stories are not
black my stories are not white my
stories are Universal they are colorful
thanks to all of you
and thanks to that wonderful man
my Oscar
shining so brightly
you are a symbol
giving hope to us and young girls
like Erin is Salome where are you girl
stand people need to see you okay
yes
and to all children little boys and
girls with all skin tones who dream that
one day they will proudly proudly carry
you
all right
I mentioned earlier Andrew and Manuel
who are filmmakers
and activist
film makers and activists
who embed Amber with that one I hate it
I can't
we embody I can write it but to say it
sometimes yeah it's hard okay to
everybody's experience and ideas of what
I talked about tonight
that's why in 2016
they chose me to become the Godmother of
a movement they created to spark peace
love and unity the connect movement
they have been fighting passionately for
human connectivity is that good yes
connect
human connectivity
look at them
oh yeah
human connectivity to bring us all
closer together again with a simple
gesture Palm to Palm okay we do that and
you also sir let's yes yes like this and
you can use the room do it too if you
want to okay
okay wait
wonderful okay
thank you
I sent Bridges
perfect
so
as
okay so how do you feel
connected
yes
okay
same position
we sent apologies to a pan to pan
especially in this time when we are so
divided
not just here but all over the world
this Zeus our values I believe in and
I'm fighting for with my camera
my voice and my life
let's use My Cry of Joys to raise our
voice voices together
camera
sun
and action
thank you very much thank you to the
academy thank you to Mr jealous
[Applause]
I love you all and thank you my darling
thank you thank you
and I want to thank
Mr George
obey her who did that beautiful gun for
me because I wanted a warrior I would
fit but she it is something like a queen
and I'm sure that I thought you were
there will be happy
thank you very much thank you